one night a servant found the Old King
had died in his sleep and ran to inform
Queen Alison
protocol dictated that the bells would
be rung and a raven sent to Dragonstone
to summon the air princess rhaenyra for
her coronation
but Alison had other plans once she saw
her dead husband's body she sealed the
room and had the servant thrown into the
black cells to ensure his silence
at the hour of the owl the Lord
commander of the kingsguards sir Kristen
Cole summoned the small Council to
inform them of the King's death so Otto
Hightower of the hand of the king and
father to Queen Allison demanded that
the succession be settled immediately
the decrepit old men of the small
Council were confused the succession was
settled in their minds the Old King had
forced the Lords of Westeros to swear
fealty to princess rhaenyra as his heir
it's a Christian Cole rightly pointed
out that her son comes before a daughter
the council argued until dawn when the
master of coin finally stood up and
declared he would have no part of
treason so Kristen Cole wisely opened
his throat with a dagger ending the
debate
none were more surprised to hear of
Prince aegon's succession than Prince
aegon himself at first the fool rejected
the crown but his mother pointed out
that his sister rhaenyra would return
such loyalty by taking his head
as the old King's trueborn son he'd
always be a threat aegon relented he was
crowned in the dragon pit and his wife
and sister Helena became Queen his
brother Eamonn flew off to win over the
few great Lords who support aegon didn't
already have the banner of the Gold
Dragon flew over King's Landing and the
red keep as aegon second of his name
ascended the iron throne
he would not sit it long
for free you can now listen to the
entire audiobook Fire and Blood On which
house of the Dragon is based and which
covers the entire Targaryen history
including current and future events of
House of the Dragon for free with a
notable trial using our Link in the
description
foreign